hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
nicht lachen challenge auf meinem kanal
wieder mal zusammen was geht bei mir
geht alles was beine hat außer stühle
und tische die wahrheit ist so ist so
nervend ist einfach sollen aber auch
immer dass man das direkt versteht
einfach ist auch einfach so rein wenn
man das einmal sah dass man ist nicht
verstanden dass nach den zehn mal da
fragst du fragt doch wenn man erzählt
mal gefragt hat das war bei mir bei dir
war so bewusst nicht mal was du nicht
verstehst du lieber eine klassische oder
wie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
weißt du das nicht meine ganze kindheit
aber ich habe nie eine casting gespielt
was hast du eingespielt früher schon
call of duty mit fünf jahren nein ich
habe ja call of duty need for speed egal
das habe ich immer auf ps2 gezogen und
sofort zu dürfen und können natürlich
[Musik]
was den blick
weißt du wieder aussiehst mich so ein
lama will was ist denn das für ein video
steht einfach auf so einem wanderweg
davon wir gerade hier gerade den garten
sonntag lagen wir hängen ganz hinten
wir haben uns auch einfach nichts mehr
zu erzählen
gestern abend haben wie zum beispiel
gefäß haben und dadurch dass wir die
letzten tage davor auch immer stunden
lang alle gefäße haben wussten nicht
mehr was man sagen soll ja ohne was zu
sagen alter einfach nur gezielt der gare
du auch genauso viel verdienen wie es
wie ich jeden einzelnen tag 35 rowling
bürger bier denn zwei pizza und comedy
gruppe
was mich heute noch an die du von mir
und hat sich deiner mutter gestern sogar
eine gesichtsmaske gemacht während wir
alle mit dabei haben die halter aus
berlin herzlichen dank neben
finanzieller unterstützung geht es
diesen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das sind alles nur so egal wie oder was
ist das hier mein bester freund
herrmann ich liebe dich
das ist anderer form spiele ich weiß
doch auch nichts
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ist es normal wenn man
gar nicht das beste sondern vers
eigentlich häufig bus gar nicht gar
nicht immer nur auf klassenfahrten oder
so bin ich bus gefahren quasdorf
klassenfahrten hinten oder vorne war
immer hinten schleudersitz begrüßt jetzt
hier mit der man in leo leo meinen
freunden muss wenn man willkommen ist
wenn man sich als gast bei uns haben das
ist ein paar tanzschritte
nice nice sandra ja kannst du das für
mich mal kurz nach tanzen
manchmal habe ich bin ist das auch
wieder sandra du bist irgendwie jeder
clip hiervon könnte es auch du sein
einfach hin machen unter straßen gleiten
aber dazu möchte ich auch gern nochmal
dance move gemacht das reicht für die
nächsten sechs jahre
[Musik]
nein ich habe meinen eigenen design
da hab ich ne goldene im victor original
und automatik den hinweisen dass 80 euro
gekostet unter 70 euro vom einkommen
hätte diese leute die sich früher mit
ihren weihnachtsgeschenken gebettelt
haben ja wann die so meinten vor wie
viel hast du bekommen bei mir war
gesamtwert so und so was war ein krasses
das weihnachtsgeschenk
ich nehme die andere person mit der wega
telefonieren ich habe mal eine
spiegelreflex zu weihnachten bekommen du
hast eine spiegelreflex bekommen ich
habe aber dafür er den flex bekommen
[Musik]
nicht mehr lange wenn ich jemanden
harfst grabungen waren meine iphone
wurde kaputt gegangen alter mann am
kreuz das machen mit - tool ist nämlich
schon nicht mehr in der lage 50 euro und
er entscheidet sich für stück klopapier
will ja ganz kurz übrigens mit klopapier
freunde mich hatten einiges darauf
angesprochen in der letzten folge ebay
jetzt habe ich eine rolle klopapier
unterschrieben habe gesagt bei 60.000
sechs verlose ich die ja weit über
60.000 mikes geschafft also in der
nächsten folge ebay fails werde ich das
ganze dann auflösen wenn die rolle
gewonnen hat also bitte
wir haben auch eine kuckucksuhr so wie
gott so richtig doch was findest du denn
lustig irgend so ein rentner der mit
einem gaming headset zum gewachsenen
lover ja aber nicht so war es genauso um
den bands zu zahlen weißt du das ist
genau dein humor und seiner anlage werde
aber auch über dem ort und seinen
bildern passen egal wie alt er ist so
traurig
das ist aber das war dann so tipps immer
bekommt die ein wirklich weiterbringen
hast du erst mal kein problem aber
einfach du hast ja nicht mal einen hügel
gegessen dagegen dass um die schafe
diese sind aber das ist eine beleidigung
oder redet ihr untereinander für mich
ist das keine beleidigung dann bin ich
extrem starken sommer lebst du noch
[Musik]
bestückt
das ist das was das ist einfach sandra
wieder das ist einfach nur bostick nein
das ist einfach wieder deuce
das einfach boston das ist einfach dumm
so dass ein land einfach boss modus
rausgehauen
[Musik]
nicht so ganz funktioniert an der stelle
wo ich das heute wieder ist allerdings
ob werden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
diese nicht lachen challenge hier mit
mir und sandra gefallen hat das gerne
einen daumen hoch und dem video hier da
scheint mir gerne in die kommentare ob
hier im bus er vorne oder hinten
gesessen habt abonniert main kanal falls
noch keine luxusware